yellow to my subscribers first of all
I've had a lot of requests about where
my Book of Eli video is I just wanted to
tell you guys my Book of Eli video is
actually on a show called the quad on
YouTube so if you want to check it out I
put the link in the sidebar go check out
my book of Eli review I just want you my
subscribers to be without it then again
I think officially half of my
subscribers came from like totally
awesome and so do you guys welcome to my
channel now this isn't the usual setting
that I have for a video one because this
is just a short video and two because
yesterday this happened go watch The
Lovely Bones yeah yeah that was a bulb
that exploded and what you don't know is
but I'm on the blue screen I have one
like right here it's like two feet from
my head and so I realized yesterday hate
that I'm standing two feet away from a
bulb that could explode and then I'll
lose my sense of hearing and I like
having the ability to hear let's go and
tell I want to stand two feet away from
an exploding bulb again I might do a
couple videos like this I don't know I
have one bulb right now that's like 10
feet away but it's not you know so I'm
okay with that
other than that all that needs to be
addressed is like I'll see Hall one for
Dexter John lifts got one for Dexter
James Cameron won Best Director and
avatar won Best Picture and Christina
Hendricks brought the goods yeah that
makes me smile so click on the link in
the sidebar to check out my Book of Eli
review